So with the shared pointer library, we've talked a little bit about like object lifetimes and that kind of life cycles
It's worth going back again to our you object and down from that hierarchy and talking actually about
What happens to an object once we create it?
So in the simplest form for just a you object unreal has a rather than saying a new you object, whatever
Unreal has its own specific function to use which is new object and that's a templated function
So we provide the type that we want to create an instance of and then that goes through a series of steps first off
We have malloc actually just like assigning setting aside the memory on our computer
We have a men set 0 which is essentially clearing out all the pre allocated all the values that might already be in that data
We just allocated
Then we call the classes constructor and that initializes our V table and initializes all properties within that block of memory
Next we copy over the archetype with a mem copy
Unreal has this thing called the class default object, which is where we get all our defaults from so a post construction
Initialization that's essentially where we copy all the values from that class default object into our as our kind of defaults
Next we have the actual get defaults function
This essentially is not opportunity to inject data from innies from config files that we might have elsewhere
So in unreal you can specify certain actors or whatever the inherit data from innies
Which lets you set that data outside of the the class itself in a config folder in config files
And so that will get pulled in at this point and then last of all
We have this function called post init properties and that's essentially our opportunity to inject
It's typically where you would inject gameplay functionality
So anything that you need to run after, you know, all the default values have been assigned
In the context of an actor
Actor is that kind of again a big fundamental building block of the game. They have it's a much more substantial classes
There's quite a lot more
Complexity to the way an actor establishes itself once we create one or once we load one in
So when it comes to spawning an actor in the kind of smallest simplest way, it would look a little bit like this
Transform for anyone who's not familiar with the term is basically just a location of rotation and a scale
It's probably a term you're familiar with from other packages
And this is how we would create an instance of an object by of an actor by spawning it
So as you can see we get access to our world. So all actors and components inherently have
knowledge of the world they're in the world is
Most of the time is the single
Global
Entity that represents your game level right now. It's a slightly complicated
Concept because the distinction between levels and worlds and unreal but the world there is one of these at runtime
Technically, there's a separate one for the editor, but we won't talk about that right now
But it's your kind of runtime world and everyone shares the same idea of the world that they're in
So you get access to that world and then you call spawn actor and this is a templated function
and you the kind of one of the simplest implementations you can do is you provide it a class to
spawn so in unreal where you have whenever you have a
C++ actor type or C++ you object type you have access to this static class
Which is basically that thing and that the class of that object
And then you just provide it a spawn transform
So a location and rotation scale to spawn at you technically don't even need to provide the transform
If you just want the object, I assume it would default to zero zero zero
But yeah, this is the most common simple one
There are plenty of overloads of this function where you can provide a little bit more detail about actors
You might want to own this actor or something like that
It's worth highlighting as well here that the templated type doesn't need to align with the class that you specify
So this is essentially just performing a cast for us. So if
It's a spawn actor a exploding barrel
This would be okay
But if that if I had my type over here is a exploding barrel
Then this would need to be at least a exploding barrel and it's for it to cast properly into the pointer
So like I said actors are quite a bit more substantial than you objects
They've got if you were to jump into the actor header
You would see it's got a lot of functionality and a lot of data in it. So there's quite a few more steps
Internally within the actor the kind of some key functions
We care about when spawning one in or generally as part of its lifecycle would be initializing components
Which is one of the first things that it does
Obviously as we spoke about before actors contain can contain many components
And if it's a blueprint actor, it needs at least one scene component
And so each of those components get individually initialized
Those components will then have functionality called on them to say, you know, we've we're initializing this component
So they'll have their own internal life cycles
But we have some functionality called before we initialize our components and just after we've initialized our components and then we call begin play
This is begin play is essentially the kind of universal the we have started in the game now
There's a few different ways that can get called but it's kind of like our
generic start point
And then over the lifecycle of an actor a really common function is our tick
I'm gonna mention about this before but tick is essentially our function that gets called once every frame by default
It's important to highlight that we can turn tick off for actors that don't need it
We can also specify a tick frequency
So by default, it's once every frame and that function the the time that that frame has taken will be passed into that function
So we have access to this Delta time
It's a concept that we'd be very familiar with for anyone who's done games programming before but just if you're not yeah
That's that's what it is
it's the change between the frames the amount of time we took from this frame to the last one and we can use that in
Things like movement where we want to smooth that out
So we're not getting sudden big jerks in movement just because our frame took longer
And
Yeah, essentially the we can specify a tick frequency specifically if we want something that is maybe ticks once every second
So we need to do something repeatedly throughout an object's lifetime, but it doesn't need to be every frame we can we can specify that
Yeah, the and then once an object gets once an actor gets destroyed we would call its end play
I should be more specific once an actor is
Removed from the world because there's a lot of different ways that that can happen which we'll go into in a moment
And essentially end play is just the opposite of begin play. It's our stripped-down function as our cleanup functionality and then
Something that would kind of in that could and would commonly invoke end play is our destroy
So it's worth kind of breaking that down specifically
This is destroy is typically the function you would take call to get rid of an actor say once it's died or something like that
And then that would call begin destroy
And then it goes through a couple of different steps and then because finish destroy and finally after that we call free
So it's only it's worth highlighting that again
We talked about this a little bit in the garbage collection when we call destroy
That's when we would get our pending kill flag gets marked up and then that would get marked up in
For our garbage collection, but it's only at the point that it gets garbage collected that are free is actually called
Technically that object still exists
You know in our memory until it gets garbage collected
So looking more in depth that kind of a full life cycle an actor as I said
There's there's quite a lot more
Context to how an actor can come about to being so you can see here on the left
This is kind of to describe actors that are already present in the world when we start and on the right here
This is an actor that we spawn in
So immediately you can see this kind of two ways that we might typically spawn an actor in we can either spawn an actor
And immediately or we can defer that spawn
the reason for this is if we have
We need to be able to inject some additional functionality or do some things to that actor
Before it actually gets kind of registered within the world properly that might be saying
Specifying that this actor owns this actor and we need to know that before begin player
Or we could assign some values or update some variables or things like that
That might be a reason we might want to defer that spawning
Or we just have the immediate spawn
And on the left here, like I said, these are the various ways that an actor might already exist in the world
So if it's just in our world and then we hit play an editor
If we have loaded into a map from another map
Or if we have called add to world gets called when we have streamed the level in
And as you can see, they a few different functions get called. So our construction gets called when we spawn it
For objects that are already in the level
Construct gets spawned as they get dragged into that level with a further foot for the first time
So in your editor, you would have construct called as you drag that actor in but construct and the posts
The execute construction on construction post out to construction that wouldn't be called as part of this flow
Because it's constructed at editor time. Whereas these are constructed at runtime
But then they share this pre the kind of steps that we spoke about before the pre initialized components initializing components the post initialized components and
Then they share this begin play and that's kind of like our standard starting point
And then after that point we just go on to the rest of the gameplay whatever we're doing. That's when ticking would occur and
Then we have this kind of similar. We have a reflection of that begin play process with our end play
So there's a whole bunch of ways that an actor could come to ending its its kind of ending play
I suppose the actor could get destroyed
When you spawn an actor, you can specify a lifetime for the actor
You can do that in blueprint or in C++
And say this is this actor only exists for three seconds
If you have something like a visual effect or maybe a bullet that you just want to automatically get cleaned up after a few seconds
You can specify a lifetime. So at the point that lifetime is exceeded it will automatically get destroyed
When we transition levels the unreal automatically just destroys every actor in the level we're in at the moment
It's not really intended the actors persist between scenes between full levels
There's slight caveat there about levels that get streamed in but yeah, mainly when we transition
Whole worlds we would clean up all the actors in that level
If we stop place or if we're in a play an editor session
Then we stop play all the actors in that game world will get destroyed if the game is just closing
Down or the game is ending. These are both situations where we would kind of begin this flow
Worth highlighting as well the end play
Actually gives you information about the way in which this actor is getting destroyed. So
We kind of had a little bit more context about precisely what is happening that has led to this actor getting destroyed
So again, we have our end play functionality is called we can override that and do any extra stuff that we need to do there
At this point our actor gets marked for a pending kill which is relevant to our garbage collection
then it gets removed from the
My you levels array of actors again if the level is transitioning that's less relevant
But obviously if this is an actor that's destroyed mid-level then it's good to know that that actor is no longer in our array of actors
And then finally later when our next garbage collection gets hit that's when the rest of this stuff occurs
We call begin destroy is ready for finish destroy gets checked against and then finally we call finish destroy
And it's after that that the memory is freed
So again just to touch about this a little bit before but just to highlight again that
The actor is still around until in memory until we get garbage collection
And it's only as garbage collection occurs that this begin destroy and finish destroy are finally called